[Music]
hey true believers I'm Lorraine and this
is the Marvel minute bringing you 60
seconds of Marvel news it's freezing
here in New York so I'm ready to heat
some things up with some hot updates
let's do it it is time to roll out the
red carpet Marvel Studios Black Panther
has not only made Marvel history but
Oscars history during last week's
Academy Awards nominations announcements
the groundbreaking film gained seven
nominations including one for Best
Picture Black Panther is the first
superhero film to be nominated in the
Best Picture category verbal studios
Avengers infinity war also received an
Academy Awards nomination for Best
Visual Effects Congrats to everyone
involved coming out this Wednesday
there's another new crop of Marvel
Comics we've got the clashing cowls of
black panther vs Deadpool number 4 if
you're looking for some buck kickin
comedy there is West Coast Avengers
number 7 or we've got to true believers
conan titles if you need some
barbarianism check out off of those at
your local comic shops later this week
and in the most delicious news Marvel's
eat the universe has returned for a
second tasty season on marvel.com check
out the first few scrumptious recipes
now and then tune in each week to see
what Marvel themed treats are chef
Justin Warner and his guests are cooking
up check out episodes on marble comm or
the marvel social media handles YUM
and that's all we have time for this
week but I will see you next time on the
Marvel minute